numbers
thank you very much to the organizers uh
for the invitation to speak
um this talk will have three parts
uh the first I will give some
mathematical background and some history
and motivation behind some of the
objects we study then I will discuss two
projects the first is more of a
practical set application to the router
numbers and then the second uh deals
with new stillensats uh certification
for Randy type numbers and I'll try to
describe some connection uh between
between the two
okay so as many of you know of course
Ramsay Theory can be described as you
know a study patterns that appear when
you have a sufficiently large
mathematical objects or patterns that
are preserved when we partition or color
that object
and the most famous results in this area
is of course Ramsay's theorem which says
that if you red blue
color the edges of a large enough
complete graph and you'll necessarily
find either a red KR or blue KS
uh but is what is not as well known is
that there are sort of Ramsey theorems
that actually predate Ramsay himself
needs or not
um
need to not start with sort of logic but
they actually had their Origins and
algebra and number Theory
what might be argued to be the first
Ramsay type theorem is called culprit's
Cube Lemma
written in this form says that for some
number of color for every number of
colors K and dimension D the there's an
N where if you K color a large enough
interval one through n you will find a
monochromatic solution to this system of
equations and the system sort of
describes an affine cube of integers
and Hobart uh proved this while he was
studying irreducibility of rational
functions so more of an algebraic
motivation
and the joke here is that it's a shame
that Hilbert didn't really uh study
these coloring principles further
otherwise he could have been things
moving on uh the next main result uh in
this area is sure's theorem which says
that again if you K color a large enough
interval one through n then there must
be this monochromatic triple or
monochromatic solution to this equation
X Plus y equals z
I'm sure
uh prove this uh well he was trying to
attack Vermont class theorem and uh he
used this to prove things about
solutions to the Sperma equation
often
often in Ramsey Theory we're interested
in the smallest such n that works and in
this case we call this the smallest n
the sure number SK
so just as a few very simple examples of
this uh so 2 happens to be five
uh it's not hard to convince yourself
that if you color one through four in
this way then you avoid monochromatic
solutions to X Plus y equals z
but it turns out no matter what you do
for one through five you will get stuck
and you can keep going so three is a
little harder but still doable
excuse me by hand
uh you can carry three color one through
thirteen while avoiding Solutions but no
matter what you do for one through
fourteen you get stuck
and I will say a bit more about the
other known shirt numbers in a little
bit but I want to sort of finish finish
this historical story
uh the next big theorem was
blunderbarton's theorem
it says again we okay color one through
n then you will necessarily find a
monochromatic length L arithmetic
progression this line of n is large
enough
but rephrased in this way you can you
can also view this as uh you must find a
monochromatic solution to this system of
equations that describe an arithmetic
progression
and again there's a number Theory
motivation this was a conjectured by
sure while studying quadratic residues
and like the sure number we can define a
Wonder Garden number to the smallest n
where this works and again it's a small
example w23 is nine these are
essentially the only three colorings
that you have but you get stuck at nine
in each case
and you can keep going with this as well
uh they're best known General balance
these numbers uh the best
generally the best accepted lower bound
uh is this finite Field construction and
the best known upper upper bound is this
funny looking uh Power Tower due to
gowers
um which actually uses some very deep
and difficult results
um
in terms of exact values we also don't
know very much we only know uh these
these seven as far as I'm as far as I'm
aware so this is hard both from an
asymptotic standpoint and a
computational standpoint
okay
so I've sort of phrased these three
theorems suggestively I phrase them all
in terms of equations
and so a natural question is okay what
about other systems of equations and is
there a way to sort of put these three
theorems under one one umbrella
and the answer is yes and this was
largely answered by rado in his first
PhD thesis which was with with sure
so again we will Define What's called
the bottle number for an equation and
this is going to be the smallest n for
which we necessarily find a
monochromatic solution to the equation
uh with Kate colors and in this language
the shirt number is just the Rado number
for X Plus y equals z
but uh round numbers behave slightly
differently in general it turns out they
don't really always exist so for this
equation 2x plus 2y equals z the two
color router number happens to be 34 but
for three colors uh you can actually
three color all the positive integers
while avoiding these Solutions
and in this case we say that the number
is in Infinity
I need one more definition uh we say
that an equation is regular if the K
clarato number exists for all K so
sure's theorem just says that the
equation X Plus y equals z is regular
and rado's single equation theorem is
sort of a direct generalization of
shirts theorem says that if I write my
equation uh in this form uh then this is
regular if and only if there's a
non-empty subset of the coefficients
that sums to zero
so something like this is regular so
four plus three minus seven is zero but
something like this is not
okay
and I'm sort of going to stop here
though I should mention that the full
version of rattles theorem does indeed
capture systems of equations and uh from
rado's Full theorem you can deduce
under Gordon's theorem and the helper
Cube Plymouth among many other things
how was the Hilbert one
I don't know it was one variable plus
sum what was it
this one
it should be homogeneous
empty set what is it
yeah x0 is is just sort of this affine
shift
um
yeah
any other questions
so what does this have to do with set
well there's been uh most of the best uh
what's the best uh balance for these
numbers
um
or exact values these numbers are due to
that solving this is going to be just a
non-exhaustive but a decent list of some
of the successes sat has had in
Computing these numbers
so something first were
uh was this Wonder button number w26
and from there there's a lot of uh study
of other various generalizations of
underwater numbers green Tau numbers
have to do with arithmetic progressions
over the Primes
and then there's another exact value for
this one department number and many
other various
generalizations of this
then Myers anesthesis uh did a very
systematic study of router numbers and
used a lot of computational techniques
that included
and there's also I did not Define this
but the three color Ramsey number uh
also uh use the set in it
and then the last three are sort of most
relevant for
uh our results uh the Pythagorean
triples problem that's the router number
for x squared plus y squared equals z
squared the two color case
and not sure number five was done in one
a few years ago by one of our audience
members
and then there's also this result on
what are called generalized three
colorster numbers which are a type of
throttle number uh done in 2019.
So based on all of this all this nice
work we decided to use you set to study
study the router numbers
so I want to go back to to share numbers
first
this is a table of all the known sure
numbers and we we're stuck at five
um instructor number five proof uh
particularly the upper bounds what's the
massive stats computation uh using Cube
and Conquer and produced arguably the
largest proof uh ever created
and this was this was our main main
motivation for for doing this
but okay so
there are so many many ways you can go
with router numbers it's not so obvious
what
what should be studied
um
but we settled on this this case this
three variable case
um two variables is not not so
interesting it's totally known uh but
three variables um still have a lot of
unanswered questions so this equation ax
plus b y equals CZ the router numbers
this equation will give you upper bounds
for any
um any other homogeneous equation with
more variables
and the two color numbers are the most
popular these have been studied uh by
far the most often but we still don't
have a general formula for uh ax plus b
y equals CZ
however if we set some of a b and c
equal to each other then we do have
exact formulas for these two cases
although they're still a bit complicated
this ax plus a y equation still has sort
of 14 different uh 14 different cases
but relatively little was done with
three or more colors so we thought that
this was a good a good place to start
so this was sort of our initial initial
computation
um
excuse me uh we did lots of computations
uh for two colors we went for the most
General General case and got a couple
thousand of them and we sort of lose an
order of magnitude with each color added
uh we got a few hundred uh three colors
and like 10 or so uh four posts so this
was this was the beginning
and looking at one of these tables
this is what we found so this is for a
times x minus y equals b z
and we got got this table uh and I've
highlighted three patterns
um so this first pattern is this blue
upper triangle here and it's not hard to
see that's all of these values are equal
to a cubed unless A and B are relative
or not relatively prime on the screen
diagonal also has a nice easy formula
it's a cubed plus a minus 1 squared
and this first First Column this red
column uh also has a nice uh polynomial
description so perhaps not as not as
obvious
okay so natural question here obviously
is okay to do these patterns continue
and the answer is yes
uh yeah we just sort of looked looked at
it and
um use guests yes
um or I think the First Column we just
uh threw into the oh yeah yes
and so the question is yeah does this
continue and the answer the answer is
yes uh all three of these patterns uh do
do indeed uh go on
okay and I should mention that this last
this last result was conjectured
um by Myers in his thesis and it implies
this other conjecture on these
generalized shirt numbers
um the generalized sure numbers are just
uh
it's the model number for an equation
that looks like the sure equation but
with more variables uh and this was
proven in 2019
um Although our results is our result is
slightly slightly stronger
okay so how do we do all of this um
so for our previous
table of this we just did a natural
satin coating but I also want to explain
how we do this as well using stats
so just the basic setup is of course
given an equation E we construct the
formula where it's satisfiable if you
know if the router number is at least n
and I won't spend too much time on this
encoding but we have variables for each
integer color pair where this variable
is set true if and only if we color I
with color C
and barring the language of the show
number five paper uh we use three types
of Clauses which we call positive
negative optional
and positive Clauses just say that each
integer gets some color I
uh negative Clauses sort of forbid
monochromatic Solutions
so we have
uh Clause of this form for each solution
in each color C
and optional Clause is to say
each integer gets exactly one color
there's just a simple example using the
sure equation three colors and
thank you
okay
so for all these numbers we just uh
produced a satisfiable formula
uh at n minus one in an unsatisfiable
formula at n and this is enough to show
the router number is equal to n
and what we did was just uh for each of
these we essentially just guess and then
find a research our way to end
and solving actually turned out to be
very very fast uh we just used out of
the box solvers mostly cateical towards
the end
um and for two or three colors these
essentially everything can be done in
under a minute
but for four colors we do some basic
symmetry breaking and uh
requires a bit more time
sort of the main our main result is
modifying this to compute infinitely
many values using a single formula
so it's all sort of hinges on this
observation
I will use uh this as a boy example
uh so we don't need all the integers in
our proof not only do we not need like
all the Clauses in the formula but we
don't need all the integers
so
uh here's how you could prove that the
upper bound here is nine
so
that lost generality we can say four is
red and we have the solution six four
six which says six must be blue
and then if you keep going okay we have
969 and 334 which of course nine three
to be red and blue
uh but then you are stuck of course it's
seven
but we do not need to use all the
numbers one through nine we could throw
out one two five and eight and proof
works just as well
so what we want to do is to describe a
set like this s that works for these
this entire fan right
so just do another quick example uh this
two color number this this family is
known to be a squared minus a minus one
and we can use this set s uh to prove it
for each each a
so again you can go to its proof If one
is red this force is a minus 1 to be
blue
and then this forces a minus 1 squared
to be red
then we will
get a contradiction fairly quickly
and this actually sort of looks like the
proof for S of 2 less than or equal to 5
but these polynomials playing the roles
of one two three four and five
okay
okay so what we can do is prove these
upper bounds by during a formula in the
same way using using these polynomials
generated exactly the same positive and
negative or positive and optional
Clauses but now our negative Clauses
will look something like this
and the sets s will describe an
unsatisfiable core for a family of
unsatisfiable cores for these this
family of equations
we're able to do is we found suitable
sets s for our families
um and we're able to get
um
these upper bounds uh in each case and
the solver does it very fast in less
than 10 seconds each time
um is it say that you have to be a
little bit careful uh the polynomials
need to be bounded in a certain way they
need to be bounded between one and the
upper Bound for every value of a or b
that you might plug in and
um
the way we generated them was a bit a
bit messy a bit complicated
[Music]
um so I don't want to get into that here
but I can say more
so yeah so that was that was pretty much
it for this this first project
um
but we have much much more uh that we're
currently working on so
the
this is known
or this this generalized sure equation
as I said this is known for for three
color three color case
um
three colors this is known to be M cubed
minus M squared minus M minus one but
based on our experiments uh it is very
likely that this is
um the analogous thing for four colors
holds holds as well
um but what we really want to do is you
know refine these methods to find these
these sets as these unsatisfiable uh
course
it said we don't really like the way the
way we did it
um right now we want to either find a
better better computational method or
use some use some math math trickery to
really describe these these minimal sets
and
um
there's there's plenty plenty of other
places you can do the exact same thing
um there are tons of other families of
product numbers that have been studied
uh non-homogeneous cases have
um showed up a lot in the literature and
you can do this with non-linear or
equations over
other billion groups as well
and using this
um big
big database for
[Music]
um
I should say
database but data for X plus b y equals
CZ seems like we should be able to use
this somehow to
get some insight on a general formula
for uh the two color case
okay
um ahead of time so I will say a little
bit more about the other the other half
of this paper which is more more
mathematical
um but another sort of interesting facet
of this is called this degree of
regularity which is defined to be the
largest k for which we get
um
a finite finite throttle number for a
given equation
um and this is not so well understood
and we're able to get to the degree of
regularity for a small small number of
equations and
um
prove some other results that determine
degree of regularity for families where
some of a B and C are set equal to each
other
but this is this is generally very
poorly understood Rado was able to
characterize two regularity
of homogeneous linear equations but
absolutely nothing
is known for uh
irregularity or higher
and this relates to what is called
boundedness conjecture
which says essentially that if you fix
the number of variables then either your
equation has to be regular or there is a
a bound on the degree of regularity
this is very difficult as far as anyone
knows and we only know the three color
case where it is shown that Delta equals
24 is good enough
but based on our computations it seems
plausible that you can knock that Delta
down down to four we don't know if there
is any equation uh with degree of
regularity
or equation of this form with derivative
regularity four or higher
moving on to the next the next project I
want to
uh first go in a totally different
direction and talk about
so we want to sort of understand
um Ramsay Theory and Ramsay type
problems through uh the lens of
polynomials in the Notions
and we can encode for instance a router
number
uh using a system of equations as well
this is an encoding over F2 or the
algebraic closure
um where we sort of have the analog of
positive negative and optional Clauses
again
say this this middle set of equations
uh it says that each variable
one to n it's some color
and then these first this first set of
monomials forbids monochromatic
Solutions
and then if you want you can include
these
equations as well that's forbid uh
integers from having multiple colors
this has no solution over F2 exactly
when the router number is at most n
and again as a simple example
um you can do this with the sure
equation two colors and five integers so
and I'm using X and Y for clarity
instead of two subscripts uh but this
system of equations will have will have
no solution
and of course I won't spend too much
time on this
I hope it's not support says that
um
the system will have no solution exactly
when we can find this identity some of
beta I times fi equal to one
LSA Nordstrom certificate and here we
were interested in the
uh degree as our complexity measure and
we Define that to be the maximal degree
among the beta I
and our goal here was to describe most
on-site certificates for router numbers
but also for other Ramsay type problems
uh more generally
okay so this is something that looks
totally totally different at first
um but this is sort of how we describe
these certificates
um so sort of these Ramsay type games
have been well studied
um and this one is called the Builder
painter game
I will describe it for model numbers so
we have a fixed equation E and positive
integers K and N see how it works is
these two players take turns
each turn Builder will select some
integer one through n and then painter
will color it
some color one through k
and other people there's objective is to
create a monochromatic solution to E
and painter is trying to delay this as
long as possible
so this number arcade tilde which we
call the online router number is going
to be the smallest number of turns where
Builder is guaranteed to win
and note that Builder will necessarily
win as long as n is at least at least
the router number
foreign
remember this equation X Plus 3y equals
3z if I play this on the sort of board
one through nine then I claim that this
online router number is at most five
because as I showed Builder can just
choose from three four six seven and
nine and still win so there's a gap
between the router number and the online
router number in this case and this will
hold more generally
this will hold this will hold more
generally so the same
same sort of thing will hold for these
families of equations that I mentioned
before
okay that's our main result here is that
using this F2 encoding
there is necessarily a Nissan sat
certificate of degree at most uh this
online router number when n is exactly
equal to the random number
but it turns out there's sort of nothing
special there's nothing special going on
about the Rado numbers here this holds
far far more generally and you can do
the same Construction
uh for any any Ramsay problem really to
work for classical multi-color Ramsay
numbers it'll work for these numbers
I've been talking about the work for
vonder Borden Hills Jewett and and so on
so I am
the tool is under time but
um
current work and future work that we
want to do is to really study the lower
bounds or these notes down south degrees
we don't have any good results in this
area and it may very well be that these
online Rado online Ramsay numbers are
really terrible we we don't know
um
these inequalities we have examples
where each of these are strict uh for
example for the sure equation for two
colors
degree is two but the sort of online
number and router number are five
so we don't really know anything about
sort of how how tight these inequalities
are and we suspect that there is a large
large gap in each case
so what we're doing now is sort of
approaching it from One Direction and
trying to understand this Builder
painter game for Rado but also other
numbers such as binder Barton and Ramsay
there are some results that are already
known for Ramsay you can sort of save
and log n edges in the online version
but we don't know if that's the best or
sort of how how well we can do in
general
okay
yeah sorry I went a little fast but
thank you
um thanks so I was I really like your
idea also of this set s to the computers
and I was wondering also for these
online numbers did you try to use uh
proof minimization to have insatisfiable
course to compute this uh we haven't we
haven't tried anything yet
yeah of course I expected this can be
actually quite helpful for this kind of
setting to really see okay which are the
numbers that were used by the solver and
then to kind of generalize it to compute
your set s or to minimize this this
online number yeah
great
to follow up on that question is there
any theoretical reason why there should
be these small subsets s that
why do you know why there's these small
subsets asked to give you
unsatisfiability right
um no that's what we're that's what
we're trying to understand a bit more
um it seems like
yeah that's that's what I wanted to
mention I we sort of don't know what
the sort of hard hard router numbers are
um because it seems like for for sure
like X Plus y equals z you really do
need sort of most of you know most or
all of the numbers all the time
um one reason one sort of
simple reason if I go back
um
here yeah yeah so one one sort of
obvious reason here we have X plus three
y equals three Z well this rearrange you
can see that X is always multiple of
three so we have a bit more structure
there uh with modular conditions
um
but it's not not so clear how to
sort of
how to make this more general or say
anything more
um I was also wondering have you studied
these these numbers where so you have n
now this this red the the the limit that
you do you have right but going beyond
that right because for example I noticed
with the Pythagorean triples that if you
have a way higher number then the
numbers that you use is can be
substantially smaller
right um so is there also knowledge of
what is the small so what's the smallest
notion in case you kind of go almost
into Infinite
right so I guess we haven't we haven't
studied studied this with these
equations necessarily though I will
mention
back here
so if I
so I sort of defined these numbers
where you're sort of playing at a fixed
fixed board one through n right
um
but you could also study the same thing
where you can allow
or arbitrary n or or all of the positive
integers and for Ramsay for the
the Ramsey online Ramsey
it is known that if you allow sort of
infinitely many vertices and you can get
an exponential Improvement there
um
and it's not not known exactly how
quickly that goes back down when you go
to the actual Ramsay number
um so that's that's one thing where we
are working on
to study study this sort of thing when n
is much larger but we don't we don't
have anything concrete to see at the
moment
therefore because at least I saw for the
pipe again triples out I noticed that
you can get way way smaller and uh the
question is I I think I I increased n to
over a million and then I got I think uh
yeah so the proofs get smaller and
smaller I think it's the proof called
out to wanted one terabyte yeah which is
still reasonable but
um the question is I say if you would go
to a billion right or uh whether you
actually might be able to get a human
human understandable kind of argument
for these kind of are more difficult
cases yeah we haven't we haven't tried
that but I think we will yeah okay thank
you
for the questions yep
the other numbers case is there an
explanation why there should be
polynomials in the coefficients yeah
um that's a that's a great question
um
or I guess you mean polynomial
uh
like this this is polynomial in the
number of variables right yeah yeah all
the other examples you gave were
polynomials in amb right
um yeah I don't I don't have a good
answer to that but uh it is that is not
true in general like sure numbers are
exponential
um but yeah I or I say sure number and
some other equations are do grow
exponentially but yeah we we don't know
hey well thank you
let's be cool